[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: All righty,
why don't we get started.
So welcome back.
Nice to see you all.
And what have we been doing
in theory of computation?
We have been talking
about Turing machines
and about the power
of Turing machines.
We started at the
beginning by showing
a bunch of decidability
theorems that
exhibit the power
of Turing machines
to calculate properties
of finite automata,
context free grammars,
and so on in some cases.
And last lecture, we talked
about the limitations
of the power of Turing
machines by proving
undecidability theorems.
So we showed that
this language A TM,
the acceptance problem
for Turing machines itself
is an undecidable problem.
That was the first of
many undecidable problems
that we're going to encounter.
And though we proved
the undecidability
of A TM using the
diagonalization
method as hopefully
you remember,
we're going to introduce
a new method which
we kind of basically
previewed last time
called the reducibility
method, which
is the way other
problems are typically
shown to be undecidable.
And so we're going to stick
with that for this lecture
and also next lecture.
We're going to be talking
about undecidability.
And I think there's going to
be a few additional discussions
after that.
But this is one of
the important themes
of the course is to
understand that threshold
between decidability
and undecidability,
or the limitations
of computation, OK.
So today, as I
mentioned, we're going
to talk about the
reducibility method
for proving problems
undecidable and also
non-turing recognizable,
Turing unrecognizable.
We're going to
introduce this notion
of a reducibility in general.
And we'll also talk about
a very specific kind
of reducibility called
the mapping reducibility.
So today as
promised, we're going
to talk about using
reducibilities
to prove problems are
undecidable, or unrecognizable.
So that's going to be
our general method,
oops, make myself
smaller, thank you.
I always forget.
Thank you for the reminder.
So using reducibilities to
prove problems are undecidable,
or unrecognizable, and
the basic way that works
is we're going to leverage
another some problem we already
know is undecidable
say, or unrecognizable
to prove other problems
are unrecognizable.
So we did a quick example
of that last time.
We're going to go over
that example again just
to set the stage.
And then we're going to talk
about that in greater detail.
So as you recall
from last time, we
had this problem
HALT TM, which is
the problem of testing
for a given Turing
machine and an input
to that Turing machine,
whether the Turing
machine halts,
either accepting or rejecting,
but just whether it halts.
Which is a somewhat different
problem, closely related
obviously, but somewhat
different than the A TM
problem, which is just
testing whether the Turing
machine accepts.
We already showed that
A TM is undecidable.
Now, conceivably, HALT
TM might be decidable.
You know, it's not
exactly the same problem.
But we're going to show
that HALT TM is likewise
undecidable.
We did this last time, but
I'm just going over it again.
I'm going to likewise show
that HALT TM is undecidable.
We could go back to the
diagonalization method
and do it from scratch.
But generally, that's
not what's done.
Generally what people do is they
use a reducibility from a known
undecidable problem.
And so what we're going to show
is a proof by contradiction
which says that if
HALT TM were decidable,
then A TM would
also be decidable.
And we know it isn't.
And that's by virtue of what we
call a reducibility from A TM
to HALT TM.
And I'll explain
with the terminology.
And we'll have a chance
to play with the concept
all lecture long.
So we're going to see all
sorts of different variations.
So as I said, we'll assume
HALT TM is decidable
and use that to show that A
TM is decidable, which we know
is not true.
So quickly going through it
because we did it already
once before, we're
going to assume
that HALT TM is decidable.
Let's say Turing machine
R is the decider.
And now we're going
to show that ATM
is decidable by constructing
a Turing machine S,
which uses R to decide A TM.
That's going to be
our contradiction.
So here is the machine S.
You have to keep in mind
what the goal of S is.
We're going to design
S to solve A TM, which
we know is not decidable.
So don't get confused by that.
We're aiming for
a contradiction.
So we're going to
use S as typically--
well, there might
be other variations.
But for now, S is going
to be used to decide A TM.
So we can try to figure
out, how can we decide A TM.
And the way we're going to do
it is use our HALT TM tester
that we assumed to have.
And we'll first
take our M and w,
where we're trying to
determine, does M accept w?
And we'll first test
whether M halts on w.
If it doesn't, we're done.
Because it couldn't
be accepting w,
M couldn't be accepting
w if it's not even
just halting on w.
So if R reports doesn't hold,
we can reject right off.
But even if R says it does
halt, we're still in good shape
because now we can run
M on w until completion
because R has promised us
that it's going to halt.
R is stated.
And R is assumed to be correct.
R is stated that M
halts on w, so now we
don't have to
worry about getting
into a loop, which
we're not allowed to do
since we're making a decider.
We're trying to
decide A TM here.
But now we can run them
on w to completion.
We can find out
what M does on w.
And then we can act accordingly.
So we're using the HALT
TM decider to decide A TM.
That's the name of
the game here, OK?
And that's a contradiction.
And so therefore our assumption
that HALT TM was decidable
had to be false.
So it's undecidable.
OK?
Important to understand
this because this
is sort of the prototype for
all of the other undecidability
proofs that we're going
to do going forward.
OK, so we can just take
a few seconds here.
If there's something that
you're not getting about this,
it's a good time to ask.
Not seeing many messages here,
or any, so why don't we go on?
But if you ask, I can get to
it next slide too, all right.
Here we go.
So here's the concept
of reducibility.
And I know, I've taught
this course, many times.
I know where the
bumpy places are
in terms of people
struggling with material.
The concept of reducibility
is a bit tricky.
So don't feel bad if you
don't get it right away.
You know, so that's
why I'm going
to try to go slowly
in this lecture
to make sure we're all
together on understanding
how reducibility works.
OK, so the concept
of reducibility
is that we say one problem
is reducible to another,
say A reducible to
B. It means that you
can use B to solve A.
That's what it means
for A to be reducible to B.
OK, so I'm going to
give a bunch of sort
of informal examples of that,
or easy examples of that.
And then we'll start
to use it for real.
So example 1, this is sort
of really outside material
from the course.
But I think it's something
you can appreciate.
You know, everybody
knows you can
measure the area of a
rectangle by measuring
the lengths of the two
sides, measuring the length
and width of the rectangle.
So in other words, if
you had the problem
of determining the area, you
could reduce that problem
to the problem of
measuring the length
and width of the rectangle.
So here, we're
taking one problem
and reducing it to
another problem.
You know, it's
conceivable that measuring
the length and width
is easier than it would
be to measure the area
directly by somehow covering
the space with tiles, is
one way of measuring it.
But it tells you, you
don't have to do that.
The problem of
measuring the area
is easier than
covering with tiles.
You can just measure the length
and width and you're done.
So reducibility
is a way of making
problems easier by translating
them into some easier problem.
So here's another example
that we've already seen.
We didn't call it
a reducibility.
But if you remember back
a couple of weeks ago,
we were talking about
the languages A NFA,
and A DFA, the acceptance
problems for NFAs and DFAs.
And we gave a way of
solving the A DFA problem.
As you remember,
the Turing machine
simulated the finite automaton.
And we solved the
NFA problem not
by doing it directly but by
converting the NFA to a DFA
and then using the
solution for A DFA.
In effect, what
we were doing was
we were reducing the A NFA
problem to the A DFA problem.
So let's do another example.
Here's a problem.
Here's an example
that you again,
probably didn't think
about it this way.
But from your homework, we
had this pusher problem,
the problem of determining
whether a pushdown
automaton ever pushes on
its stack for any input.
I know a bunch of
you were struggling
with that problem working
on it, hopefully solving it
in one way or another.
So there's one way to solve
it is in effect by reducing
the pusher problem to the
E CFG the emptiness for CFG
which is the equivalent
to the emptiness for PDAs.
I mean, this is the
solution I had in mind,
which is a particularly
simple and short solution.
Of course, not
the only solution.
You can take your
pushdown automaton
where you're trying to
determine if it ever pushes.
And you can take the states
that are about to make a push.
And instead of making
them make a push,
you make them accept states.
And you get rid of the
original accept states.
So now you've converted
this automaton
to one that accepts every time
the original push on automaton
pushes.
And it accepts, and then has to
move to the end of the input,
of course.
So it goes into an
accept state and moves
to the end of the input.
So every time the original
machine was about to push,
the new machine that
you're just creating here
is going to go into an accept
state at the end of the input.
Now to test whether the original
machine ever uses stack,
it's enough to test whether
the new machine ever
accepts an S string.
OK, so that's a way.
I don't want to overcomplicate
this right here and get
you thinking about
the homework again.
But this is a way of reducing
one problem to another problem.
And if you don't
quite get this one,
just focus on the
other two examples.
I don't want to spend time on
the homework set 2 right now.
So we can address that all
separately if you want.
It's also the solution
that's written up
in the solution set that's
posted on the home page
by the way.
OK, so getting
back to let's see,
thinking about reducibility.
What I have in mind, again,
this is sort of rephrasing it,
but I'm trying to hammer it in
that if A is reducible to B,
then solving B gives
a solution to A.
Because that's what happens
in each of these examples.
Now, how are we
going to use that?
We're going to use that
in the following two ways.
One is to observe that, if
A is reducible to B and B
is an easy problem,
then A must also
be easy because we have
a way of converting
A problems into B problems.
We have a way of solving
A using B. So B is easy.
Then now you can
solve A too easily.
Because you can solve A
using B, which is easy.
Maybe that's clearest
up here in example 1,
where measuring the area might
seem at first glance hard.
You could have to walk
out over the whole area.
But it's not hard
because you only
have to measure the
length and the width.
So the fact that B is easy
tells you that A is easy.
But actually, this
is not the way
we're going to be using
it most typically.
We're going to be most
typically using it
in the second version, which is
a little bit more convoluted.
But this is the way you're going
to have to get used to this.
So if A is reducible
to B, and you
know A is hard,
undecidable, unrecognizable,
whatever the form of
hard you care about,
if you know A is hard,
and A is reducible to B,
then that tells you B
also has to be hard.
Why?
Because if B were easy,
then A would be easy.
But we're assuming
that A is hard.
So B also has to be hard.
OK, so I'm inverting
the logic here.
But this is
logically equivalent.
So you have to mull
that over a bit.
So why don't you
think about that.
And let me just take a
few questions on the chat
and don't forget the
TAs are there too.
So they're happy to
answer your questions.
Don't make them sit
there lonely, all right.
So somebody is
asking, is it possible
that A is reducible to B and
that B is also reducible to A?
So that's a good question.
That can certainly happen.
In that case in a
certain sense, A and B
are going to be equivalent.
So solving 1 is going to be
just as easy or hard as solving
the other one, OK?
So they're going to be
equivalent from the perspective
of the difficulty
of solving them.
So somebody is asking--
and this is a
perennial confusion--
so in the previous
slide here, I think
I'll just flip back to it here.
So which direction are we doing?
Are we reducing A TM to
HALT TM or HALT TM to A TM?
The way it's written on the
slide is what I have in mind.
Here we're reducing
A TM to HALT TM
because we're using
HALT TM to solve A TM.
And that's reducing
A TM to HALT TM.
Just like here,
measuring the area
is reducible to measuring
the lengths of the sides,
we're using measuring the length
of the sides to solve the area.
So we're reducing the area
to the lengths, the area
to the length of the sides.
But I know you're going
to have to play with it,
digest it, get used to it.
All right, OK, so
let's continue.
OK, so as I said,
this latter one
because the focus on
this course is mainly
on the limitations
of computation.
So we're going to be
looking at ways of showing
problems or difficulty.
It could be difficult in
principle, like undecidable.
Or it could be
difficult in terms
of complexity, which
is what we're going
to focus on in the second half.
But in both cases,
we're going to be using
the concept of reducibility.
So reducibility is
going to be a theme.
You've got to get comfortable
with reducibility, OK.
So we're going to be
focusing more on the notion
that if you reduce A to
B, and you know A is hard,
that tells you B is also hard.
OK, so I'm going to
say that a few times
during the course
of today's lecture
to try to help you get it.
All right, here's a check in.
A little bit sort
of off to the side.
But I thought it was
a fun check in more.
The question is, some
people say biology
is reducible to physics.
Well, maybe everything
is reducible to physics
since physics tells you about
the laws of the universe.
And biology is part
of the universe.
So my question to
you is, do you think?
And there's no
right answer here.
Do you think, in
your opinion, is
biology reducible to physics?
Maybe yes, or maybe there are
some things like consciousness
which cannot be
reduced to physics.
Or maybe we don't know.
So I'm curious to
know your thoughts.
But it does kind
of use in a sense
the notion of
reducible in the spirit
of what I have in mind here.
In the sense that if you could
fully understand physics,
would that allow you to
fully understand biology?
OK, here we are.
We're almost-- kind of
interesting, though not too
unexpected I suppose.
So we are, I think,
just about done.
5 seconds, pick anything if
you want to get credit for this
and you haven't selected yet.
Ready to go, ending polling.
Here are the results.
And as I say, there's
no right answer here.
But if I had been in the
class, I would have picked B.
But I'm not surprised,
especially in an MIT crowd
that A is the winner, all right.
Let's continue.
OK, so now we're going to
use reducibility again.
This is going to be yet another
example like the HALT TM
example, but a
little bit harder.
And we're going
to be doing this.
You know, next
lecture, we're going
to be doing more
reducibilities but much harder.
So we really got to get
really comfortable, all right.
I want to show E TMs.
So E TM is the emptiness
problem for Turing machines.
Is this language empty?
I'm just going to
give you a machine.
I want to know, is this
language empty or not?
Does it accept something
or is this language empty?
That's going to be
undecidable, no surprise, proof
by contradiction.
And we're going to show that
A TM is reducible to E TM.
So these things often
take a very similar form.
And I'm going to try
to use the same form.
So if you're
feeling shaky on it,
at least you'll get the form
of the way the solution goes
and that will help you maybe
plug-in to solve problems, OK.
So proof by
contradiction, assume
that E TM is decidable,
opposite of what
we've been trying to show.
And then show that
A TM is decidable,
which you know is false.
So we'll say we have
a decider for A TM,
R, using the same
letters on purpose
here just to try to get
the pattern for you,
so R deciding E TM.
Construct S deciding A TM, OK.
So now, let's think about
it together for a minute
before I just put it up there.
So S, I'm trying to
make a decider for A TM,
using my decider for the
emptiness problem, OK?
So we have R, which can tell us
whether M's language is empty.
So why don't we
just, I don't know,
stick M into that emptiness
tester and see what it says?
I'm not saying this
is the solution,
but this is how one might
think about coming up
with the solution.
So are you with me?
We're going to take M, we
have an emptiness tester.
Let's take M and plug it
into R, see what R says.
R is going to come back and
tell us whether M's language is
empty or not.
Now, one of those answers
will make us happy.
Why?
Suppose R tells us that
M's language is empty.
Why is that good?
With that, we're done.
Because S is trying
to figure out,
we're trying to
figure out exactly,
somebody told me the
answer which is correct.
Because now we can reject.
If M's language is
empty, it's clearly not
accepting w because it's
not accepting anything.
So if R says M's language
is empty, then we're good.
The only problem is we also
say M's language is not empty.
And then what do we know?
Well, not much, not much
that's useful for testing
whether M accepts w.
We just know M
accepts something.
But that something
may or may not be w.
OK, so what do we do?
Well, the problem is
that M is possibly
accepting all sorts of
strings besides w, which are
kind of mucking up the works.
They're interfering with
the solution that we like.
We'd like to be
able to use R on M
to tell us whether
M is accepting w.
But M is accepting other things.
And that's making the
picture complicated.
So what I propose
we do, why don't we
modify M so that it never
accepts anything besides w?
The very first thing M
does in the modified form
is it looks at
its input and sees
whether it's different from w.
If it's different from w,
it immediately rejects.
Now we take that
modified machine,
and we feed it into
the emptiness tester.
Now the emptiness
tester is going
to give us the
information we're looking
for because if the emptiness
tester says the modified
machines language
is empty, well,
we know that M is
not accepting w
because we haven't changed how
M behaves when it's given w.
But if R says M's
language is not empty,
well, then it must be
that M is accepting w.
Because we've
already filtered out
all of the other
possibilities when
we've modified the machine.
So let me repeat
that on the slide
and write it down a
little bit more formally.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to transform M
to a new Turing machine.
I'm going to call it
M sub w to emphasize
the fact that this new
machine depends on W.
It's going to actually
have w built into as part
of the rules of the machine.
So for a different w,
we're going to end up
with a different machine here.
So this is a machine
whose structure is
going to depend on knowing w.
And that machine is
going to be very much
like the original
machine M, except that
when it gets an input,
let's say it's called X now,
that machine is going
to compare X with w
and reject if it's not equal.
Otherwise, if X is equal to
w, it's going to run M on w
as before.
So it's not going to change the
behavior when the input is w.
It's only going to change the
behavior when the input is
something different
than w, and then it's
going to reject, all right.
So I'm going to look
at two aspects of this.
First, let's understand the
language of this new machine.
And then we'll
also talk about how
we go about doing
this transformation.
So first of all,
just for emphasis,
so Mw works just like M.
It has all the rules of M
in it, except some extra rules.
It always at the
very first step,
it tests whether X
is equal to w or not.
And if it's not
equal to, it rejects.
Not equal to, reject.
So the language of
that new machine
is either going to
be just the string
w when M accepts w because
everything else is filtered
out.
Or the empty set if
M rejects something.
So it's important that you
understand the behavior,
at least, of this new machine.
It's just like M except
filtering out all
of the inputs which are not w.
Those are going to be
automatically rejected.
So it's also important
that S be able to make
this transformation.
But I claim that you'll
have to accept this
if you don't totally see it.
But the transformation
is simply taking M
and adding some new rules,
some new transitions and states
so that the very first
thing that M sub w does
is it just has a
sequence of moves
where it's checking that the
input string is equal to w
or not.
And if it's not equal
to w, it just rejects.
So it's easy to modify
M. You could easily
write a program which
would modify the states
and transitions of M to make it
do that test at the beginning.
So I'm not going to elaborate
on those kinds of things
in the future.
But just for the
very first time,
I just want to make sure you
understand that we're not
doing anything fishy here.
This is a completely legitimate
thing for S to be able to do.
So S can modify M
to this new machine
Mw, which filters
that new machine,
filters out all strings
except for w and rejects them.
So S takes that new machine, and
what is it going to do with it?
Is it ever going to
run that machine?
No.
This machine is built
not for running.
for feeding into R.
Because as you remember,
feeding M into R
had the problem that M might
accept things besides w.
And that confuses the result
that we get from R in the sense
that it's not useful.
But if we feed Mw
into R, now we're
good because if the information
about whether Mw's language is
empty from over here tells us
whether or not M accepts w.
If Mw's language is not
empty, then M accepts w.
If M's language is
empty, M rejects w.
OK, so starting to get
some good questions here.
Let me just finish
the description of S.
So somebody is asking here.
So this is an
excellent question.
How do we know that Mw
halts on w, or whatever?
We don't.
Mw may not halt on w.
We don't care.
We're never going to
run Mw on anything.
We're going to take
Mw as a machine,
and we're going to feed it
into R as a description.
We are going to take
the description of Mw
and feed it into R.
Then it's R's problem.
But R has been assumed to
answer emptiness testing.
So we just took the original
machine, modified it
so that the only possible
thing it could accept is w.
And now feed it into
the emptiness tester
to see whether its
language is empty or not.
Now if its language
is not empty,
it has to be accepting
w because it's built
not to accept anything else.
So we don't care whether
Mw might end up looping.
We're never going to run Mw.
I acknowledge, it's a
leap for many of you.
So you're going to
have to mull it over.
So we're going to use R to test
whether Mw's language is empty.
If yes, that means
that M rejects w.
So then we're going
to reject, if we
know that Mw's
language is empty,
that must have been
that M rejected w.
So now as an A TM decider,
which is what S is,
S is supposed to
reject, which is what we
have here in the description.
And if no, that means the
language is not empty.
So M accepts w, and so
therefore we're accepting.
So there's a little bit
of a twist here also.
OK, so let's take some more.
I'm expecting some
questions here.
So somebody is
asking, how do you
determine if the
language is decidable?
I mean, that's what we're doing.
You can show a language
is decidable by exhibiting
a Turing machine
which decides it.
And you can show a
language is not decidable,
which is what we're
doing here by proving
that it's not possible for a
Turing machine to decide it.
You know, we did
that first with A TM.
We got that contradiction
by diagonalization.
And here we're
doing a reducibility
to show as the method
of proof, all right.
Let's continue.
So now we're going to
talk about a special kind.
So far we talked
about reducibility.
We didn't define
it in a precise way
because there are
several different ways
to get at the notion of
reducibility precisely.
And I'm going to introduce
a one version, which is
a little bit more restrictive.
I mean, somewhat more
restrictive and a little bit
different way of looking at it
than we have been doing so far.
But there were going to be
some benefits to looking
at this particular kind of
reducibility, which we're
calling mapping reducibility.
It's going to have several
benefits for us immediately
and down the road.
But this is also
a little technical
so don't get scared off.
It might look
complicated at first.
But we'll try to
unpack it for you, OK.
So first of all, we have
to first of all talk
about the notion of a
computable function.
So generally when we've
had Turing machines,
they're doing yes, no.
They're doing accept,
reject kinds of things.
So it's like a function,
just sort of a computing,
sort of a binary function.
For here, we're going to want to
talk about Turing machines that
are computing a
function which converts
one string to another string.
So it's mapping from
strings to strings.
And it could be like the
function which reverses
the string, for example.
That's one possible function
you could be having here.
But there's of course zillions
of possible functions here.
And we're going to talk about
functions that you can compute
with the Turing machine.
And that basically means
you provide the input
to the function as input
to the Turing machine.
And the output of the function,
the value of the function
comes out as the output
of the Turing machine,
which let's just say it
leaves that value on its tape
when it halts.
It halts with the value of
the function on the tape.
But just, we're thinking
about algorithms here.
Come up with your
favorite method
of thinking about algorithms.
It has an input and an output.
And the algorithm just
computes the function
by taking as input w,
and the output is f of w.
It doesn't have to
be a Turing machine.
Just any algorithm that
can compute something
is good enough.
They are all equivalent.
And now we're going to use
this notion of a function
that you can compute to
define a kind of reducibility
called mapping reducibility.
I'm going to say that
A is mapping reducible
to B, written with this less
than or equal to sub M symbol.
And you're going
to see that a lot.
It's on the homework
also by the way.
If there is some computable
function as I just described,
where whenever w is
in A, f of w is in B.
And the way to think about
it is with this picture.
So A and B are
languages, written like,
here's A and here's B.
And now there are strings.
So w might be in A.
It might be out of A.
And you think of you're trying
to solve A. You're trying
to decide membership in
A. So you want to test
whether w is in A or not.
A mapping reducible
is a function
which maps things
from this space
over to that space in a way
that strings that are in A
get mapped to strings
that are in B.
So if you start out with
w in A, f of w is in B.
And if w is not in A, then f
of w is not in B. Pictorially
it's a simple idea.
We'll have to make
sure we understand
why this fits with our
concept of reducibility.
But we'll do that.
But anyway, let's
first understand
just what we're doing here.
We're just coming up
with a function that
can do this kind of a mapping.
It sort of translates
problems which
inputs which may or may not be
in A into other strings which
may or may not be in B.
But sort of maintaining
the same membership property.
So if you start out
with something in A,
when you apply f, you're going
to end up with something in B.
And conversely, if you're not in
A, then you won't be in B, OK?
Somebody is asking, so just
a couple of questions here.
Not necessarily 1-to-1?
No, so the function
doesn't have to be 1-to-1.
There could be multiple things
that map to the same point.
And is there any
restriction on the alphabet?
No.
So before we actually
get into the example,
let me try to give
you a sense about why
we call this a reducibility.
And the reason is, suppose
we have such an f which can
do the mapping as I described.
And we also have a way of
deciding membership in B.
So B is decidable.
So that's going to tell us
right away that A is decidable.
Because if you have some
input, and you want to know,
is it an A or not, you can now
apply f and test whether f of w
is in B. So the
test of w is in A,
you're going to instead
test whether f of w is in B.
And we're assuming that shows
that A is reducible to B.
So if you could solve the B
problem, that also gives you
a way to solve the A problem.
So again, we're going to
say this several times
in several different ways.
So if you didn't quite
get it yet, don't panic.
So here is going
to be an example.
Sort of building on what
we just showed last time
in the previous
slide, A TM, we're
going to show how
A TM is actually
mapping reducible to
the complement of E TM.
And the complement
is necessary here.
The computable function
that we're going to give,
which is basically,
the computable function
is going to translate
problems about A TM
to problems about E TM
because we're mapping reducing
A TM to the complement of E TM.
So what we're doing here is with
mapping M and w to the machine
Mw.
Kind of in a way, we're
boiling out the essence,
boiling down to the
essence of the proof
that we gave in
the previous slide.
This is really the
core of the proof.
This translation of Mw
where you want to know,
is M accepting w to a new
machine Mw where you're testing
whether Mw's language is empty.
And so remember Mw from before.
It's the machine
that filters out
all the non-w's
and rejects them.
And the reason why this
reduction function works
is that Mw is in A TM,
if and only if M sub w
is in the complement of A TM.
So M accepts w exactly when
Mw's language is not empty, OK?
So M accepts w if and
only if the language of Mw
is not empty.
So you have to mull this
over a bit to realize it's--
I know this can be
a little tricky.
But I think what we're
going to do here,
I think we're at the
time for the break.
So oh, no, there's
one more slide.
I apologize.
So let's talk
about this and then
we're going to have
our coffee break.
So these properties
are really going
to be getting at what
makes mapping reducibility
fit with our understanding of
what a reducibility should be.
So if A is mapping reducible
to B, and B is decidable,
then so is A. So that
fits with what we want.
Because if A is reducible to B,
and B is easy, then A is easy.
So here easy means decidable.
And here is the proof.
Let's take a Turing
machine that decides B
and construct a Turing machine
that decides A as claimed,
S operates like this.
It takes its input,
computes f of that input,
tests whether f of w
is in B using the R
machine that we were assuming.
We have R deciding B.
And if R halts then
output the same result.
So if R accepts,
we're going to accept.
If R halts and
rejects, we'll reject.
And of course we're going
to be similarly running R.
So if R is not
going to be halting,
we are not going to
end up halting either.
OK?
So the corollary is,
and this is the way
we're going to be using
it, if A is reducible to B
and A is undecidable, then so
is B. So this is as I mentioned,
the focus for us is going
to be on undecidability.
And you may want
to think about A
is like the A TM problem
which we know is undecidable.
We're going to show
the A TM is mapping
reducible to some other problem
to show that other problem is
undecidable.
And the important
thing about mapping
reducibility is that it
also applies to recognizes.
So if A is mapping
reducible to B,
and B is Turing
recognizable, then so is A.
So if you're reducing A
to a recognizable problem,
then A is also
recognizable, same proof.
Because you can just
map your w to f of w
and feed it into the recognizer.
That's going to give
you a recognizer
for the original language.
And the corollary is that if
A is mapping reducible to B,
and A is unrecognizable,
then so is B.
So this is again
that inverted logic.
So now I think we're--
oops, I meant to put
this picture up earlier.
OK, so here's a check in.
It will be more of a
check in for me to see
how well you're following me.
So these are some properties--
so I'll give you a
minute here to think
about this-- some properties
of mapping reducibility.
Suppose A is mapping reducible
to B, what can we conclude?
Does that mean that
we can flip it around?
If A is mapping
reducible to B, does that
mean that B is mapping
reducible to A?
What about this one?
If A is mapping reducible
to B, is the complement
of A mapping reducible
to the complement of B,
or maybe neither?
So you can check all that apply,
multiple choice, 5 seconds.
Sorry to pressure you, but
we have to move on here.
Pick anything.
If you don't know, OK,
1, 2, 3, the end, OK.
Well, the majority is correct.
In fact, it's only
B. Now, A really
is not in the spirit
of reducibility.
Because as suggested even by
the inequality sign there,
A being reducible to B is really
a rather different thing than B
being reducible to A.
So that's something.
We're not going to
prove that right here.
But that's something that
you could think about.
But part B, I think,
if you just look here
at the definition of
mapping reducibility,
it maps strings in
to in and out to out.
Well, that's just going to be if
you exchange in and out as you
do when you're flipping
compliments on both sides,
it's still by the same f going
to still work as a mapping
reduction, OK?
So now we're at
our coffee break.
So we're going to take
five minutes here,
and I'll be happy to
take questions here.
Don't forget the TAs.
They're here to.
OK.
OK, so this is a
fair question here.
You know, so we had this
notion of a general reduction
and a mapping reduction.
They are not the same.
So any time you have
a mapping reduction,
it's going to be an example of
a general reduction, but not
the other way around.
So if you go back and
look at the reduction
that we offered
for HALT TM where
we showed A TM is reducible
to HALT TM where we started,
it's actually not
a mapping reduction
because we're doing
something more complicated
than translating an A
TM problem to a HALT TM.
We're kind of using
the HALT TM decider
in a more complicated way.
And there are cases where
that's actually necessary.
So we're not going
to discuss that here.
But it's actually kind of an
interesting homework problem
perhaps, or some kind of
a problem to think about.
So Turing machines for f's,
it's not really a decider,
but it has to be--
well, I guess it does have
to be a decider in a way.
It's always halts.
The Turing machines for
f has to always halt.
It always has to have an output.
So f for the computing the
function always has to halt.
So someone is asking me,
can I explain the statement
that if error halts, then
output the same result?
I just mean that in that
previous slide, or two
slides back, if R accepts,
halts and accepts,
then we're going
to halt and accept.
And if R halts and rejects,
then we halt and reject.
So I don't know if
this is a good idea,
but we can just
pull that back here.
So that was the statement here.
If our halts and
output the same result,
I just mean that S is
going to do the same.
You know, we're translating
an A problem to a B problem,
and then answering
the B problem.
And we're going to give the same
value, the same answer there.
So whatever R says,
we're going to say too,
if that's helpful, all right.
Boy, this is a
good question here.
If A is reducible to B, why
can't we just get B reducible
to A by inverting the function?
That's a great question.
I like that question.
The reason is because the
function that's mapping onto B
doesn't have to be onto,
subjective I guess.
So if it was onto, so
if it covered all of B,
then I think then you would
get an invertible function.
And you would get the reduction
going the other way as well.
But though, I'm not sure
what happens when you have.
It doesn't matter if
you have collisions.
It turns out that's
not going to matter.
But anyway, let's not get
it too complicated here.
But the problem with inverting
it is that it's not necessarily
onto the whole range of B.
So we're kind of
out of time here.
Is A reducible to A compliment?
Let me just handle that.
No, not necessarily.
It's reducible.
A is reducible to A complement,
but not mapping reducible
to A compliment.
But A is general
reducible to A compliment.
So actually we'll talk.
I have a slide on that.
So let us move on, OK?
Mapping I think, it's
actually this line, mapping
versus general reducibility.
So we're going to
contrast it to a bit.
So mapping reducibility,
which is what we've just
been talking about
has this picture,
which is, I think, a very
useful picture to remember.
And because I like to think
of a mapping reduction
as a problem translator.
Your problem is sort
of in the A domain.
And the mapping reduction allows
you to translate that problem
into the B domain.
OK, and then if you have a way
of solving it in the B domain,
combining that
with the reduction,
you get a solution to the
problem in the A domain.
So that's why if A is
mapping reducible to B,
and B is solvable, then
A is also solvable.
So mapping reduction is a
special kind of reducibility,
as opposed to the general
notion in general reducibility
where we started.
And it's particularly useful to
prove Turing unrecognizability.
So when you want to prove
Turing unrecognizability,
as we'll see, general
reducibility is not fine
enough in a way, it doesn't
sort of differentiate things
as well as mapping
reducibility does.
And for that reason,
it's not always
going to be useful to prove
Turing unrecognizability.
It's better for
proving undecidability.
So what we're
calling reducibility,
or general reducibility
is where we just
use a solvent for B
to solve A in sort
of a most general possible way.
So I'm writing that
as a picture here.
If you want to solve
A, you're going
to use the B solver as
a subroutine to solve A.
That's the way we did the HALT
TM reduction at the beginning.
But we didn't necessarily
translate an A TM problem
to a HALT TM problem.
It's slightly different.
So you can go back
and look at that.
So I find that people
struggle more with the mapping
reducibility concept.
And that the
general reducibility
is what people naturally
gravitate towards.
And so in some sense,
it's conceptually simpler.
And it's useful to
proving undecidability.
But you really have to
be comfortable with both.
And especially in
the complexity part,
we're going to be focusing
on mapping reducibility.
So one noteworthy difference
here as sort of foreshadowed
by the person who made
this question, which
is a good question,
is that A is reducible
using a general reduction to A
compliment, which kind of makes
sense.
I mean, if I can test whether
things are in A compliment,
well, I can test
whether things are in A.
You just invert the answer.
But A may not be mapping
reducible to A compliment
because there is a very
special kind of reduction.
And you have to just translate
things in the language
to things in the language,
and things out of the language
to things out of the language.
And they don't necessarily
allow you to do that inversion.
So for example, A
TM complement is not
mapping reducible to A TM.
Because as we
pointed out, anything
that's reducible to a
recognizable language
is going to be recognizable.
Anything mapping reducible
to a recognizable language
is going to be recognizable.
But we know that A TM
complement is not recognizable.
We showed that before.
So it couldn't be mapping
reducible to A TM.
It's coming a little
fast I realize.
You're going to
have to digest it.
So here's the last
check in for today.
OK, we showed that if A
is mapping reducible to B,
and B is Turing
recognizable, then so is A.
And so let's just say
that again carefully.
If A is mapping reducible to B,
and B is Turing recognizable,
then so is A. And here are the
emphasis on Turing recognizable
as opposed to decidable.
Is the same true if we use
general reducibility instead
of mapping reducibility?
So you got it?
So we're saying A is
mapping reducible to B
using this picture over here.
And we're going to assume
that B is Turing recognizable,
so that we have a
machine which halts an
accepts when you're
inside B, and you know,
is going to reject possibly
a looping when you're not
inside B.
Now, that allows you to get
a recognizer for A if you
have a mapping reduction.
Does it always work to
give you a recognizer
if you have just a
general reduction?
If you just have now,
assuming you have a B solver,
and you're going to build
an A solver out of that.
OK, so mull that over while
I'm setting this thing up.
Well, the right answer is
winning, but not by much.
I suppose I shouldn't
be laughing about it.
But I knew that this is
going to be challenging.
So I think it's the
kind of thing you're
going to have to work at.
So let's see we're almost
done here, 5 seconds to go.
Better answer that, I
can see a few of you,
either you've left
the room, or you're--
OK, 2 seconds, 1, 2, 3.
Somebody hasn't answered it.
There we go.
So the correct answer
is B. It's not the same.
The reason is that
in general, I mean,
the picture is right here.
Let's see, how do
I explain this?
So we know that a
language is going to be--
OK, if we're using
general disability
and A is just reducible to B,
we know that a
language is always
reducible to its complement
in using general reducibility.
So if this were true,
then we would have here
so if this were true,
when a language is
reducible to its complement,
if the complement were
recognizable, the language
would also be recognizable.
That clearly is not going to
be the case because you know,
A TM complement is
reducible to A TM
using general reducibility.
But A TM complement
is not recognizable
even though A TM
is recognizable.
So we kind of have a proof
that this has to be no.
But as you can see, I'm even
getting myself confused.
So you have to stare at it.
So let me see, we can try to
take a couple of questions
see if I can clear up
people's confusion.
So why again, is A
reducible to its complement
in the general sense?
So I'm saying, if
you have a solver,
if you have a decider
for A compliment,
it gives you a solver for
A. You just ask the solver,
is the string in
the language or not?
And now you just give
the opposite answer
if you want to solve the
complimentary problem.
So the A complement is
general reducible to A.
You just invert the answer for
whatever the solver is doing
for A. But you can't just
do that inversion when
you have a mapping reduction.
It's a much more kind of
specific translation that's
allowed.
I mean, the
fundamental difference
between general reducibility
and mapping reducibility,
I'm trying to bring it out here.
It's just a difference
in the nature
of the way things are used.
Mapping reducibility
is a special kind
of general reducibility.
So to answer the
question about what's
the fundamental difference,
one is using the problem
as a subroutine and the one is
using it as a transformation.
Anyway, I think we're going
to have to move on here.
And I am going to have couple
of examples which may help.
And then, there are office
hours too after the lecture.
OK, oh, yeah, so I wanted
to again to help you.
I'm putting these down
as sort of templates
for how do you use reducibility.
I'm not saying you should
just apply things blindly.
But I think it's sometimes
good just to see the pattern
and then to understand
how the pattern works.
So once you just start
to understand the pattern
of how things are used.
So to show a language
is undecidable,
to prove a language
B is undecidable,
show undecidable
languages reducible to B.
Using just a general reduction
is going to be good enough.
And the template
for that is, assume
we have R deciding
B, which you then
can use as a subroutine when
you make a Turing machine S
deciding A. And that's going
to be your contradiction.
If A was originally shown to
be known to be undecidable.
But now to prove something
unrecognizable, this kind
of reduction it's not
as restrictive enough
because this kind of reduction
allows for complementation
which is not going to be
satisfactory when you're trying
to prove Turing unrecognizable.
So you're going to have to
prohibit the complementation.
And that's really one of
the effects of the mapping
reducibility if that sort of is
getting at the essence of it.
So you're going to show an
unTuring of a recognizable A
is mapping reducible to
B. Often you start out
with the complement of A
TM, which is a language
we know is Turing unrecognizable
as we showed before,
OK, here the template is you
give the reduction function f,
that computable function, OK.
So here are going
to be two examples,
one showing that E TM is
Turing unrecognizable.
We showed it was
undecidable before.
Now we're going to show
it's even in a sense worse.
It's not even recognizable.
And the way we'll do that is to
reduce a known unrecognizable
language to E TM in
the emptiness language.
So here is the
picture that we have
when we're doing
mapping reductions.
We're going to map strings that
are in the complement of A TM,
so strings that
are outside of A TM
if you wish to strings where the
language is empty to machines
where the language is empty.
And here are strings
describing machines which are
where the language is empty.
And here we're going
to take A TM problems
and map them to machines where
the language is not empty.
And the thing that's
going to do the trick
is going to be that
same reduction function
that we saw earlier.
We're going to take that
machine w from before,
the machine that filters
out all the non-w's.
And we're going to take Mw,
which is an A TM compliment
problem.
So if M rejects w that it's
in the complement of A TM,
and that's supposed to map
to a string, a machine which
is where the language
is empty, OK.
So if Mw is in the complement
of A TM, so M rejects w,
then Mw's language
is going to be empty,
which is what you
want to have happen.
Let me move on to my last.
I mean, this example is
in a way kind of similar
to the one we did before.
And I really want to get
to the last example here.
OK, so we'll have to
just talk through this
rather than having it build.
Let's take EQ TM.
That's the equivalence
problem for Turing machines.
Do they recognize
the same language?
So this is a language
of a new kind for us.
This is a language where
neither it nor its complement
are going to be recognizable,
Turing recognizable.
So the way we get that is, the
way we show problems are not
recognizable is mapping reduce
a non-recognizable language
to typically the
complement of A TM.
So we're going to mapping
reduce the complement of A TM
to both EQ TM and to
the complement of EQ TM
to show that both of those
are not recognizable.
And here we're going to
introduce a new machine
that we're going to be building
inside the reduction function.
And that's going to be a
machine I'm going to call Tw.
And Tw is a machine that
always behaves the way
M behaves on w for every input.
So if M accepts w, T is
going to accept everything.
If M rejects w, T is going
to reject everything.
So it copies the behavior
of M on w onto all inputs.
And the way I describe
that machine Tw is it
ignores its input.
Whatever the input is,
it just simulates M on w.
You could easily
give an M and w,
you can build the machine Tw.
It just always runs M on w,
no matter what input it gets.
And so now we're going
to give a function which
maps A TM problems
which have the form Mw.
So it's an A TM
compliment problem.
So this want to test
if M accepts w or not.
So that's an A TM
compliment-type problem.
And I want to map that to an
EQ TM problem with the form--
you know, EQ TM problems
repairs the machine
now, and where going to
be testing equivalence.
So I'm just trying to give
you the form of the output
of the reduction function f.
And specifically,
what it's going
to look like is when we
have f is processing on Mw,
it's going to
produce two machines.
One of them is going to
be Tw which always behaves
the way M behaves on w but
expanded to all inputs,
and then a machine I'm going
to call T reject, which just is
designed to reject everything.
Now, just walk through
the logic with me.
If M rejects w, Tw
rejects everything.
And so we'll be equivalent
to the machine T reject.
That's what we want.
If M rejects w, so we're in
the language A TM compliment,
then these two machines
that I produce for you are
going to be in the EQ TM line.
That's what I want
to have happen
for a reduction from A
TM compliment to EQ TM.
Similarly, to do
part 2, I'm going
to make here a different f,
maybe I should call it f prime,
all right, f1 and f2 for
the two different parts.
So these are two different f's.
I'm going to make f here.
Instead of generating
Tw and T reject,
I'm going to have
Tw and T accept
which is a Turing machine
that always accepts its input.
Now, if M rejects w,
it's in A TM compliment,
then Tw is going to
reject everything.
And it's going to be different
from its companion here,
T accept.
And so it won't be
in EQ TM compliment.
But if M accepts w, then Tw
is going to accept everything.
And it's going to be
equivalent to T accept.
And you will be equivalent.
So the here is where we're
taking A TM compliment
and mapping it to the
compliment, the EQ TM.
Too many compliments
here I realize.
Compliments are confusing.
But anyway, why don't
you mull this over.
And just to summarize, OK,
we're out of time here.
But why do we use reducing
when we talk about reductions?
It's because when
we reduce A to B,
we kind of bring A's difficulty
down to B's difficulty, that's
where the reducing comes from.
Or we bring B's difficulty
up to A's difficulty,
because it's really A's
difficulty relative to B
that we're talking about
when we're reducing A to B.
So that's why the term reducing
seems a little out of place
when we're proving things
undecidable, or unrecognizable.
But that's where
it's coming from.
Anyway, quick
review, we introduced
the reducibility method.
We defined mapping
reducibility as a special kind
of reducibility.
We showed E TM as undecidable
and unrecognizable.
And that EQ TM is
both, it and it's
complement are unrecognizable.
So we're out of time.
I will shut this down.
But I'll take a few
questions here actually.
I'll stick around
for a few questions.
And then I'll move to the other
chat room for office hours, OK?
So question, go over the case
for the complement of EQ TM.
So I will do that.
So that's in this slide here.
OK, so this is proof
part 2 for the person
who asked me to go over it.
But I think it's helpful
for those of you who might
be a little bit shaky on this.
I want to mapping reduce
the complement of A TM
to the complement of EQ TM.
By the way, I don't know if
this is going to be helpful.
But as we pointed out in
the check in a while back,
that's completely equivalent
to having a mapping
reduction from A TM to EQ TM.
You can complement
both sides, and you
get an equivalent statement.
Maybe let's stick with the
compliments here though.
I hope that doesn't make
it too confusing, OK.
We're trying to show
the complement of A TM
is mapping reducible to
the complement of EQ TM.
What does that mean?
So that means when M rejects
w, so you're in the compliment,
we want the two Turing
machines to be inequivalent.
No, yeah, so we're in
the compliment of EQ TM.
So in other words, when we're
in the complement of A TM,
we want the result of the f to
be in the complement of EQ TM.
So in other words,
when M rejects w,
the two machines
should be inequivalent.
Right?
When M accepts w, the two
machines should be equivalent.
Because when we're not in this
language, so we're in A TM,
we want to be not
in that language.
So we should be in EQ TM.
So when M accepts w, we
should be equivalent.
When M rejects w, we
should be inequivalent.
That's what we want.
Let's go down here.
So if M accepts w, we want
them to-- so when M accepts w,
we want them to be equivalent.
So if M accepts w, Tw
accepts everything.
And it's equivalent to T accept.
When M rejects w, Tw
rejects everything.
And so it's not
equivalent to the machine
that accepts everything.
So just go through
the logic yourself.
You'll see why it's working.
All right, so,
bye, bye, everyone.